-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated performer
and best-selling author.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Amy Sedaris.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Oh, wow!
Hi, Seth.
-You look fantastic, as always.
What a wonderful choice
you've made,
your sartorial style unrivaled.
-Well, I was a little limited
on what I could wear
because John Early is --
-The fantastic John Early,
wonderful comedian.
-Well, I own
the apartment above me,
and he's staying there,
overstaying his visit
for like two weeks.
But all my getting-ready dresses
are up there.
So I was like,
I don't want to go up there
when someone's staying up there
because then I see
an unmade bed, underpants.
-Oh, so you're not going
out of respect for them.
You don't want
to spin yourself out.
-I don't want to spin myself out
and see an extra pair of shoes
that don't belong to him.
So anyway, this is what I had.
But I love this dress.
-So this isn't even in your
first choice line of dresses.
-No. I've had this for five
years and I've never washed it.
Shoo, shoo, shoo,
shoo, shoo, shoo!
How dare you?
-He'll text me messages
and say, "I crawled down
the fire escape
and watched you sleep
last night."
-That's what your upstairs --
-Yeah.
This is what John Early told me.
Then he's like, "When I told
the doorman I was leaving,
they burst into tears."
And then I'll run into him
on the street,
and it's 1:00 in the afternoon,
and he's like, "I just woke up."
And I'm like,
"John, what is going on?"
He's panfrying croissants
up there.
-Oh, my God.
-But he's a good guest.
-I don't know.
It doesn't sound like
he's a good guest.
-He is. He is. He is.
-Now, I like doing a check-in
every time you're here.
about your dear rabbit...
-Tina Bunny.
-...Tina Bunny.
-Yes.
-Now, Tina Bunny
is a male rabbit.
-Mm-hmm.
-But you have had --
The first time you were
on the show nine years ago,
we discussed Tina.
-I brought Tina home that night,
and then I was freaking out
that I made a mistake.
This is my third rabbit.
They told me it was a girl.
Then four years later,
they told me it was a boy.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-So you are a fair--
You consider yourself somewhat
of an expert on rabbits?
-I am an expert.
I have a badge.
I go to people's houses.
I educate them.
-But it took you four years
to know that Tina was a boy.
-It's tough.
Yeah.
They were trying to insert
a catheter and they said,
"Amy, this is a boy bunny."
-I will say, you cannot tell
from the photo, but this is --
-Look at him.
He's chewed a few things.
-He has chewed a few things.
But that is his right
as a rabbit.
-Yes.
-Getting up there in age.
How long does a rabbit go?
-Well, my last rabbit
lived to be 12,
which is old for a bunny.
Tina's 10, but all of a sudden,
out of nowhere,
he started wetting my bed,
peeing in my bed.
I don't know why.
I think it's behavioral.
-You don't think it's age?
-No, because I have experience
with senior bunnies
and I think
his kidneys are fine.
But -- So I ordered -- I went
to a surgical supply store
and I ordered a bunch
of those reusable medical,
you know, bed pads, whatever.
Yeah.
-Yeah. Okay.
-But they arrived to my
apartment building unwrapped
in just, like, saran that said,
"Amy Sedaris, Apartment 4C,"
so everyone in my building
thinks I'm wetting my bed,
easily,
'cause I'll be down in
the laundry room folding them.
But anyway,
he stopped peeing in my bed.
Now he just goes --
he just leaves little droppings.
They look like peppercorns.
It's no big deal.
So I safety-pin --
If you have a pad
that's 48 by 48,
that'll cover a queen-size bed.
But they're hard to find.
And so I safety-pinned it on top
of my, you know, bedspread
so in case it happens.
It happens between 2:30
and 3:00 in the morning.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-He's just really dialed in
to that one certain window.
-I don't know why.
I mean, I went through --
During the strike, you know,
I went through
a George Michael hole.
I'm post-hole now,
but I was like --
-George Michael the singer?
-Yes.
-Yeah, okay.
-The "Wham!" documentary.
Then I got obsessed with that.
Then I got obsessed with him.
And maybe I was just so,
you know, obsessed with it
that I was pulling focus from
my attention to Tina, maybe,
and he was just getting even.
-I see.
-My acupuncturist --
-You're saying that maybe Tina
was wetting the bed on purpose
because you were
too into George Michael?
-Maybe, maybe.
-Yeah.
-And then my acupuncturist said,
"Well, did you ask Tina?
Did you talk to Tina?"
And I'm like, "Yes."
And he's like,
"What did Tina say?"
And I'm like, "Nothing."
And I haven't been back
to that acupuncturist.
-Yeah, that doesn't seem like
it's an acupuncturist's
place to say.
-Oh, my God.
So, yeah, that was something.
-Did you buy or are you renting
the apartment
next door to yours?
-Okay, so then another apartment
opened up in my building
right next door,
and I thought, "Well, this
would be a good investment."
So I just use it
as a storage unit.
So I keep my hay in there,
luggage and petticoats.
-Okay.
-But I do have Wi-Fi.
-Well, that's great.
Yeah.
-Fudge Pot. Fudge Pot's
the name of my Wi-Fi.
-You're giving away your Wi-Fi?
Oh, that's just the name
of the Wi-Fi.
You're not giving out the
password, just the name of it.
Fudge Pot and then do your best.
So these are the sort of things
you would see over there.
That's a small amount of hay.
This is the sort of --
I guess it's good
for you to say there's Wi-Fi,
'cause I think if you walked
into an apartment full of hay,
you might think it was
an Amish person.
There might not be Wi-Fi
or a need for Wi-Fi.
-It reeks of goats, trust me.
But I can't imagine --
I mean, to combine
my apartment --
It's crazy to have
three apartments in one building
and they're not attached,
but, you know,
the idea of having to, you know,
put a hole in my wall...
You know, since my husband died,
I don't have anybody who can
take care of that stuff for me.
I don't want to think
about knobs and wallpaper.
-Who wants to think
about knobs and wallpaper?
But you're living
your best life.
Knobs and wallpaper is just
going to slow you down.
-It's crazy.
-Now, when your neighbors
see giant boxes of hay
getting delivered,
do you think they look at that
the same way they look
at the pee pads?
-That I'm a stoner.
They probably think it's just
weed coming out of my house.
Big boxes of weed.
-Yeah, giant see-through
plastic bags of hay.
-Well, you said
you had a goat before.
You have goats?
-I've never had a goat.
My father-in-law had a goat.
-Same thing.
-Yeah, no.
-Really?
-Yeah, I inherited it.
It was part of my dowries
that I inherited.
He was like, "Will you take
my daughter's hand?"
And I'm like,
"Not without the goat."
-I always wanted a goat.
-Yeah, I don't think you do.
-No, I know, yeah.
-You know, he misses
his goat a great deal
and talks about it lovingly.
I did not find the goat
had a lot of charisma.
-What was the goat's name?
-Raisin.
-[ Laughs ]
That's cute.
-And based on what
they leave everywhere...
-Yeah.
-Not a bad --
Peppercorn would have been
a good name.
-Peppercorns or capers.
It's no big deal.
-Capers. Capers would be
a very funny name for a goat.
-Oh, yeah. Capers.
It would be adorable.
-Capers would be a great name
for a kid's book about goat --
a goat who pulled crimes.
-Oh, yes. Oh, yes.
-Or solved them.
Capers the goat.
-Yes.
-Yeah, and he'd be
a goat burglar.
It would be like a cat burglar,
but you would, like,
definitely hear them.
-I would buy that book.
-Alright, great.
Well, let's work on it together.
I have a bunch more
questions for you.
We'll be right back with more
from Amy Sedaris.